do believe that women have more power
than we actually realize because even
back in the day like I'm reading um The
Iliad right now and um a lot of Wars
will start because of women I think
women realize it to be honest
book lined up but I just feel like women
aren't realizing the amount of power
that they have
I actually said there's a lot of
crutches that we have in society that
are making us feel like we have this
power but I feel like it's a bit on um
I think there's just as we have an upper
select portion of men who might be seen
as pre-select or you know upper echelon
yeah yeah no I'm I agree I feel like a
portion of men who maybe don't relate to
that top tier who are well aware of the
fact that a lot of women are well aware
of the power that they hold I think some
aren't that I think you know ignorance
is bliss I mean ignorance is bliss but I
think there's actual ignorance as well
like so what kind of power do you mean
um we have the power to you know
Inspire men to carry ourselves in the
way that
you know not all of them but will
encourage them to treat us in a
different way and I think if women band
together and actually started to maybe
car ourselves in more of a modest way
the one as I said unpopular opinion I'm
probably gonna have a lot of that here
but I feel like we start to carry
ourselves in a certain way then you know
I don't want to say schooling guys but
just carrying ourselves in a certain way
well but I think the problem is after
birth control you can't go back because
there's always going to be a girl that
puts her tits out to to get to get
something like whether it's only fans
whether it's just being like the side
chick whether it's because the problem
is after birth control it gave us the
ability to basically girls that are
fours fives and sixes to sleep with the
eights nines and ten so everyone's screw
in the same 2010 15 of guys and the
issue is like after birth control like
you can't go back but I think that's I
think we've just entered a realm where
women are given more choice but I think
they don't they don't realize the power
of the choices
because they still were because we
because we've been conditioned in such a
way that we're most women not most women
but some women feel they they fall into
that category of feeling victimized well
it's because women like to be victims
yeah and I and I think that's and I
think I think a lot of people like to be
victims because I think most people
don't like taking responsibility for
themselves
but the thing is the thing is men aren't
bailed out women are always bailed out
of a bad decision they're homeless
there's women's shelters there's no
men's shelter there's not not by and
large would you say every every bad
decision a woman makes she's bailed out
of in some way or another
the most of the time you know and man
it's not the same is it not no
definitely okay like the thing is the
thing is reality hits men hard so for
example if a girl gets fat right we have
body positivity there's no body
positivity for men they don't give a
[ __ ] thank you there's no like like and
and if um if a girl gets like sleeps
with a ton of people there's [ __ ]
shaming and so like they take away the
things that men care about but they
don't do that to women
like like even so if we if we get fat
we're bailed out of that decision
because there's body positivity if we
sleep around we're bailed out we're
bailed out of that decision so if we if
we decide to be [ __ ] we're bailed out
because there's birth control if that
fails we're bailed out because of
abortion if that fails and you keep the
kid and you're homeless you're bailed
out because there's women in children's
centers if if that doesn't work there's
some government program and here I'm not
I'm not sure what it is but there's
always some government program paying
out single mothers so it's like whatever
we do we're bailed out you know who has
that and and you know he has that many
bailouts or that many
um back doors that they can actually go
through do you know the only other group
of people that have that many backdoors
children oh
true just saying Yeah question do you
think women have too many choices yeah I
do think too many choices is I I think
that we all have choices that we are
unaware of
um but do you think too many choices is
actually a bad thing because I actually
agree even four but this is not just for
women this is foreign I think so because
we don't understand that there's
consequences like
well that's the whole thing about the
whole baby daddy baby mama culture like
that whole or what are the consequences
of me doing this I've always said to
people anyone can have sex with anyone
they want to I'm not going to tell
people not to have sex but have it in a
way where you're not creating a
generation of children right that are
going to be you know well and the
narrative is that there's a bunch of
deadbeat dads that aren't taking care of
their kids and that oh she just got
finessed or she just you know fell in
love like and even even when I I bring
like baby mothers on here it's always
the guy it's never anything with them or
I picked wrong there's no accountability
for their actions it's always I picked
wrong therefore putting it on the guy
and I'd like to hear I said I'd like to
hear the guys version yeah there's a lot
because baby mothers say a lot they say
oh my baby daddy's this is that and I'm
toxic yeah I wonder what the guys would
be saying about you do you know what I
mean like what would guys like how would
they talk to talk about you as a
co-parent how would they talk about you
as as a partner in general do you know I
mean we don't get to hear that narrative
so it's like okay cool when of the
reasons probably why Kevin Samuel said
you don't get any hiding your baby
daddies he's like you know what you
picked him like it's what you've done
and so much can I just say Sierra yep
I have a question do you look like
Sierra you look like Sierra do I look
like Sierra
no I'm saying I'm saying like this is
this is this is a girl that's a nine and
then
I was right about to say before
everybody said this I was about to say
people a lot people love because it's
relatable to go to the famous examples
yeah sure but I just want to say even
though you've just said it my point was
going to be people go to the high-end
relatable examples of this but what do
they well I mean they're there really
they're not average Jane though but we
can see them though yeah they'll
probably go to that average James com
average James for like it's a relatable
example why is it relatable you know
what going back to what the lady was
saying before in the green dress I feel
what she's saying because you know
really even just let me know I really
disagree I feel what she's saying
because even though she has got two
children etc etc The Way She carries
herself a man could fall in love with
her really yes
but that's like women are emotional so
you're looking at this from a girl's
point of view because you're thinking
like oh if I met a guy and he just
Charmed me the right way like I could
fall in love and like a lot of girls do
like they'll say oh I never did that
that and that and then their next
boyfriend is that like men are more
logical it's like a cost and a minus
issues okay like so she looks she can
look great and then keep a letter I'll
fall in love with her but he knows at
the end of the day he's going to be
taking on her two boys yeah so now he's
got a way up okay cool I might love her
but I'm gonna be one taking over our
household two going into a household
with two boys who know I'm not their
father yeah like you know I mean like
all of these stuff has got a way up so
it's like yeah you know you can have two
children and look good but like I said
on the quote-unquote dating Market are
guys looking for you and she would
rather by the way
she clearly what I took from earlier on
his key that was somebody who would
rather be with nobody yeah than be with
anybody who it was felt like wasn't on
her Plateau yeah so that's fine
but then the conundrum again is the
Magnum who you view on your Plateau want
what exactly from you and then the men
and then The Men Who and then the men
who made because you see one thing
people don't necessarily talk about is
the fact that right you know what when
men say that the sort of men who would
step into a pre-made family and yeah
some men say that you know that's that's
a little weaker than than the man who
who is not doing that but I will say any
man that does that to be a stepdad
actually I think do you think you're
stronger then I think I'll